SPEAKER 1: Hi everyone.
I'm very, very excited to
welcome to Google Michael
Kupperman, who's going to be
talking about his new book "All
the Answers" and about his
family's history with "Quiz
Kids" and the early days
of celebrity culture.
Mr. Kupperman is an Eisner
winning cartoonist, author.
He's done video stuff.
I've been a big fan
of his for many years.
But I think there's no better
place to start with his work
than his new book,
"All the Answers."
Mr. Kupperman.
MICHAEL KUPPERMAN:
Thank you, Alex.
Thank you.
Hello.
OK.
Are we-- Are we alive?
Hi.
OK.
Great.
Hello.
I'm very excited to be here.
My family uses
Google all the time.
And my son is obsessed with it,
in particular, Google Street
View.
He's always telling me, he's
just seen the Google Street
View car.
And sometimes, he
turns out to be right.
Google is also part of the
story I'm about to tell you,
the story of how
I created my book,
"All the Answers," which
came out in May of this year.
On the cover, it's
called a graphic memoir.
But I sometimes think
a better description
might be graphic auto noir.
In some ways it's
a detective story,
one in which an
individual-- me--
discovers-- investigates the
past of a member of his family,
but in doing so discovers
the hidden limitations
that have dominated his life.
My name is Michael Kupperman.
For most of my career,
I've been a humorist,
underground comic
artist, and Illustrator.
You might have seen my work
in or on the "New Yorker,"
"Fortune," the "New York
Times," "Adult Swim," "Vice,"
"Saturday Night Live,"
"Heavy Metal," "Playboy,"
and many other places.
Until recently, all
my sequential work
has been humorous,
until this book.
In 2010, my father,
Joel Kupperman,
retired from the
University of Connecticut,
where he had taught
for 50 years.
He seemed more relaxed
than he had ever been.
Things that used to bother
him didn't trouble him at all,
or so it seemed.
And when I asked if he could
talk to me about his childhood,
he said he wouldn't mind.
This was huge.
His formative years had been a
forbidden subject in my family
for my entire life.
All the way through my
childhood, any mention of them
would visibly upset him.
I was astonished that
I might have a chance
to finally hear something
from him about his life when
he'd been a Quiz Kid.
"Quiz Kids" was a show
that was on national radio
and then on national TV.
On it, five children
would compete
to answer questions
sent in by listeners.
My father had first appeared on
it when he was five years old
and had stayed on
it until he was 16.
I'm going to play you two quick
excerpts of the radio version.
I've edited these way down.
But even so, you'll be able to
tell that entertainment back
then moved at a different,
more leisurely pace.
This is how the show opened.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- The "Quiz Kids," presented
by the makers of Alka-Seltzer
and One-A-Day brand vitamin.
- If a brick weighs one
pound plus one half brick,
how much does the brick weigh?
That's the first question
for the Quiz Kids tonight.
I wonder if you
folks at home can
work it out before the
children get their hands up.
Well you'd better work
fast, because here they are,
The Quiz Kids.
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHAEL KUPPERMAN:
That's enough.
And this is my father
answering a question.
He's 6 and 3/4 years old here.
And the celebrity
judge is Jack Benny.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Well, 5 and a half times
2 equals 11, times 3 and 1/7
equals 34 and 4/7.
- 34 and 4/7 is right!
Good for you!
[APPLAUSE]
Aw, that's marvelous.
- I had 33 and 1/2.
I was just a little
bit off there.
I'm sorry.
I must have figured that wrong.
- I think you left--
- 33--
- Joel, after the
broadcast, will you
get together with the judge
and explain it to him?
- Well, you have to
multiply it by 2, and then--
[LAUGHTER]
- I did it!
I multiplied.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Wait a minute.
Joel--
- You see, you multiply by 2.
And then you multiply
that by 3 and 1/7.
- I know.
I did it twice.
I multiplied it twice.
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHAEL KUPPERMAN: My father
had a reported IQ of 219
and could do sophisticated
math tricks in his head.
The press promoted
him as a genius
equal to Einstein and Socrates.
During most of World War
II, he was a household name
and universally beloved.
Everybody wanted to meet him.
Everybody wanted to hear the
cute and wise things that
came out of his lisping mouth.
He was huge.
He played himself in a movie--
1944's "Chip off the Old Block,"
starring Donald O'Connor.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hey, sonny.
Who are you?
- I'm Joel Kupperman.
- Well, aren't you kind
of small to be wandering--
Joel Kupperman?
The Quiz Kid?
- Sure.
- Say, you're the problem child.
No problem is too tough for you.
- Yeah, but can
you keep a secret?
- Sure.
- They're not so tough.
- Says you.
I'd hate to meet one
in a dark classroom.
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHAEL KUPPERMAN: The star
Quiz Kids toured America
every month, making appearances
and selling war bonds.
This is my father's schedule.
They put on shows
where they'd compete
with senators, ballplayers,
movie stars, professors,
scientists.
They toured military
and Naval institutions,
visited hospitals,
posed for pictures,
and sat on strangers laps a lot.
By the end of the war, they had
raised more than $120 million
for the war effort.
I had not understood how
famous he really was.
I had known-- we
all knew-- that he
had been on radio
and then TV for years
and that it hadn't
been fun for him.
I'd heard his name mentioned
on "Rocky and Bullwinkle."
I'd seen him mocked
in "Radio Days."
I'd been told he'd been an
inspiration for Salinger.
But all these are just details.
I'd never understood the
context for his fame.
And fame without
context is meaningless.
His fame had seemed
meaningless to me.
This was one of the things
I wanted to understand.
And I wanted to try to make
a connection with my father.
We'd never had a real
relationship as adults.
And I thought this would
bring us closer together.
As it turned out, now that he
could tell me his perspective,
he couldn't remember
most of it anyway.
He'd had experiences that seemed
fantastical and impossibly
glamorous.
But all he'd wanted
to do was forget them.
He remembered that he thought
Jack Benny genuinely didn't
like him.
Everything else was vague,
a memory of a memory.
The one thing that
he was emphatic about
was he wasn't a real prodigy.
He'd been built up by the
producers of "Quiz Kids"
as pro-Semitic propaganda.
Once he'd said it out loud, he
repeated it to me every time
I saw him for the
next few months.
It was the war, and they
wanted a cute Jewish child.
He'd obviously been
thinking about it--
that one aspect of
it-- for decades.
This idea took a long
time to sink into my mind,
partly because I'd
been raised not
to think of myself as Jewish.
My mother is Scandinavian.
And when we'd gone to
churches, they'd been Lutheran.
But when I started to think
about my father's Jewishness,
and I plugged this
idea into his story,
it suddenly made
so much more sense.
The sentimentality
which surrounded him
took on a more
charged symbolic tone.
A fairly cute kid who
can do math quite well
has never been such a big
deal at any other time
in American history.
It could only have happened
with a Jewish child during a war
that many people saw as
a fight to save Jews.
I think there were
other things going on.
A lowering infant mortality
rate and the spread of media
meant that children
could be appreciated
for their adorableness
instead of being grimly
shepherded into adulthood.
But the Jewishness was
certainly a big part
of my father's appeal.
I still wasn't sure what kind of
story I would be able to tell.
But after my father
was diagnosed
with dementia in December 2012,
I decided I was going to try.
I thought maybe I could do
research and confront him
with truths I had discovered.
And this would unlock
memories or perhaps even slow
or reverse his dementia.
I didn't know then that
this wasn't possible.
The basic story was obvious.
My grandmother was an
ambitious stage mother
who'd pushed my father
into show business.
He'd been a sensation on
"Quiz Kids" when he'd started.
But he stayed on
the show too long,
until he was an
awkward teenager on TV,
where everyone could see him.
I'm going to show you a short
clip of him answering questions
on the TV version
when he was 15.
The guest host is Fran Allison.
This show was being broadcast
at this time on NBC at 8:30 PM
on Fridays.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Take out 1 cup from
the coffee to the milk.
You'll have x plus
1 cups in the milk.
And of those x plus 1 cups, x
are coffee, and 1 is of milk.
So when you transfer a cup back,
of that cup, 1 over x plus 1
will be of coffee, while x
over x plus 1 will be of milk.
So if you take the 1 over
x plus 1 away from the 1,
you'd-- let's see, x plus 1--
you'd get x over x plus 1 cups
of coffee left in the milk.
And you'd have that
much milk in the coffee.
So it'd come out even.
- You know, Joel,
if one were just
determined to find out the
answer to this question,
it would be much cheaper to
have someone like you around.
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHAEL KUPPERMAN: Other
kids hated my father by then,
because their parents had all
told them to be more like him.
After finally leaving
the show, his life
had been hell until he left
the country for a while.
I wanted to know more.
During 2013 and 2014, I spent
countless hours researching.
In the real world, I visited
Paley Center and their library,
where the librarian
Jane Klain showed me
the typewritten
notes that were kept
on index cards of
early NBC broadcasts,
and Columbia
University, where I went
through the bequested papers
of the "Quiz Kid" producer.
But most of my research during
that time was done online.
And Google was the net
I used to pull material
from the vast ocean
of the internet.
I'd follow basic
search terms for hours,
discovering new facts
or details that I'd
use to refine my next search.
I'd discover a
hint of something,
follow it to a certainty,
hunt for the evidence.
I scoured old radio sites,
news archives, auction sites,
and anywhere that
had information.
I searched Google
News and Google Books,
sometimes quite frustrated
by the cryptic snippet
views of 70-year-old books.
But I found out quite a lot.
To give an example,
I noticed a quote
by Orson Wells that suggested
he had met my father.
I searched obsessively until
I found an entire newspaper
column about my father meeting
Marlene Dietrich and Orson
Wells.
I kept searching.
And I never found a picture of
my dad with Marlene Dietrich,
but I did find this picture on
an auction site of Orson Wells
doing a magic trick for him.
My father looks delighted,
but if you follow his eyes,
you can see he's looking
off to the right.
Because of the newspaper
account of this moment,
I know that at
this exact second,
someone off camera to the right
has told him Orson has rabbits
and he can pet them.
He wasn't interested in or
impressed by Orson Wells
and his magic at
all, although Orson
didn't take it personally.
There are kinds of
research you can do now
on the internet that would
have been at the very least
extremely difficult in the past,
and very likely impossible.
You can trace the
history of an idea,
for example, the idea
of child prodigy,
first used in the second
half of the 19th century.
And you can trace the
origins of untruths.
A lot of the cute
things my father said
were obviously made up.
And in fact, I've been
able to trace some of them
to scripted dialogue my father
delivered in radio shows.
Sometimes another Quiz Kid
will say something clever.
And within a few weeks it's
being reported as something
my father said.
It definitely seems,
looking at all the evidence,
that my father's specialness was
being deliberately exaggerated
by some columnists
and reporters.
One person I became aware
of through the internet
was the brilliant producer of
"Quiz Kids," Lewis G Cowan, who
as it turned out was one
of the people in charge
of American radio propaganda
during the war, which
seemed like a huge
coincidence given
what my father had been saying
and everything I had noticed.
Lewis G Cowan, born Cohen,
was a fascinating person.
A very smart man, he later
invented the television game
show with "$64,000 Question"
and became president
of CBS's television division.
After leaving "Quiz
Kids" and the country,
my father came back
to television one
more time to appear
on the spin-off
of Cowan's show, "The $64,000
Challenge," a CBS TV program.
Apparently, the show
had been rigged.
Although my father claimed
barely to remember,
he insisted only that I
shouldn't tell anyone.
Lewis G Cowan had had an
enormous amount of influence
on my father's life.
And my father didn't
remember him at all.
But as I was
starting to realize,
my father's
pre-dementia memory gaps
meant more than I had seen.
To not remember
your crazy showbiz
experiences when
you were 6 or 7--
that could be said to be normal.
But he'd claim not to
remember a lot of stuff
from when he'd been a teenager
and in his 20s that it
seemed would have been
impossible to forget--
being violently bullied
by your roommates
at college, for instance.
I found descriptions online
by a former roommate,
who'd become a passionate
racist and white nationalist.
But my father denied that the
bullying had ever happened.
The racist seemed quite crazy.
But I believed him.
My father had erased
memories from his mind
because they were too
much for him to handle.
The real story was beginning
to appear in front of me.
And the story was trauma.
Even if I couldn't find
details of his experiences,
I could see their
shape in the imprint
that had remained on him.
And I couldn't stop
thinking about how
the kid I kept reading about
and listening to in old radio
recordings was in some ways
a very different person
from the father I knew.
The kid loved baseball.
He loved comedy and could
be extremely funny himself.
He could play the piano.
I had never seen or heard
my father mention baseball,
perform comedy,
or play the piano,
or even let on that he could.
Decades earlier, he
had told my mother
his game show experience.
And between what she
remembered and my research,
I was able to put
together how the game
show had tricked my father
into feeling dishonest.
He'd come back
this one last time,
because suddenly game shows
were paying big money.
And he thought he'd
be smart and do
what he'd done for a
decade one last time
and make some money
for his future.
He'd only made $18,000
from "Quiz Kids."
And people were easily making
10 times that in one week
on the bigger shows.
He didn't know that the
sponsors had seized control
of the process and
demanded the right
to choose the winners
through dishonest means.
His first appearance on
the show went smoothly.
And the sponsor
must have liked him,
because before the next show,
another contestant approached
him and showed him facts
in a book that turned out
to be the answers to
that night's question.
There's no recording
of the show.
But I'm quite sure
that my father only
realized what was happening when
he was live on air answering
the question.
He would have gone
ahead and answered it.
And then he left,
making it clear
he wouldn't be back,
with the producers almost
certainly begging him
not to say anything.
He was never on TV again and
refused all interview requests
for the rest of his life.
He became a philosopher
and devoted himself
to studying character,
morality, and ethics.
It had definitely
been his mother
that had setup that last
disastrous TV appearance.
Who knows if she
knew it was rigged
or would have cared if she did.
She still dreamed that he
could become a television
personality, even after it
was clear he was really not
suited for it and hated
everything about it.
This was something else online
news archives showed me,
that my grandmother had
maintained friendships
with newspaper columnists
and was feeding them
items about my father in
hopes of stoking interest.
She couldn't stop.
She couldn't let it go.
A couple of years
after his quiz show
experience, the whole enterprise
came crashing to the ground,
as seen in the movie,
"Quiz Show," a movie
my father refused to see.
During the hearings,
"Quiz Kids" was brought up
as a show that had maybe
not been completely honest.
The kids had been
softballed questions
about subjects they
knew very well.
And again, my grandmother was
eager to talk to the press.
After all this, I don't think
he ever really forgave her.
And yet I don't think he could
ever admit this to himself.
Now I know that I
should have been
able to see the size
of his fame reflected
in the size of his trauma.
And now that I could
see the effects on him,
I couldn't stop noticing
the effects on me.
The man I'd thought of as a
mild-mannered and repressed
professor was a
traumatized ex-child-star.
The timeline of my life
suddenly looked very different.
I interviewed my
father one last time,
trying to get some
reaction out of him
with everything I'd learned.
I couldn't stop
myself from asking
why he hadn't helped me with
homework like his father had.
What he said next
still rings in my ears.
Nobody told me I was supposed to
build a relationship with you.
In a way, he was more
honest than he'd ever been.
This was our last
coherent conversation.
Let me be clear.
I did an enormous amount of
research on this project.
But one of the main
things I did was think--
really think-- about my
father and my family.
Obviously, by this time,
I was wrestling with a lot
of emotions about it.
But I felt ready to start
trying to make a book.
Between 2013 and
the middle of 2015,
I produced three drafts
which weren't good enough.
This was a very painful period
as I tried to shape this story
and wrestled with my feelings.
What I was doing wasn't working.
And I couldn't figure
out how to fix it.
The thing that really
saved me was cleaning out
my parents' house in
Mansfield, Connecticut.
My wife and I had,
by this point,
spent years in cleaning out
the house, which my parents had
largely abandoned, partly
out of filial obligation
and partly because
we were trying
to use it as some version
of a vacation house.
But it was uncomfortable,
too far away
from New York, and always
more work than it was worth.
It was horribly full of stuff.
My parents had never
thrown anything away.
I threw mountains of junk
away, recycled it, burned it,
filled dumpsters.
And there was always more.
But finally, it yielded results.
In a corner of my
father's study,
well hidden in a secret
space behind other books,
were five scrap books that
my father had obviously
hidden decades earlier
and then forgotten.
Even when he'd wanted to
help me uncover his past,
he hadn't remembered them.
They turned out to contain
an exhaustive record
of my father's
"Quiz Kid" career--
newspaper clippings,
itineraries, tickets, scripts,
photographs, passes, autographs,
an avalanche of paper.
One of them turned out to
belong to his sister, my Aunt
Harriet, who had briefly
been a "Quiz Kid" herself.
It hadn't lasted though.
And she'd been given
the role of being
a housekeeper for her father,
so her mother and brother
could go touring around and
meeting Hollywood stars.
She obviously hadn't
wanted her scrapbook.
And it was easy
to understand why.
There was a lot of
withheld information--
emotion in these scrapbooks,
a lot of frustrated hopes.
And they were full of
information and insights.
The way that they'd
been so well-concealed
and completely forgotten
was very telling.
They brought new life to the
story I was trying to tell.
And in fact, their discovery
provided a narrative jolt that
starts the engine of my book.
It was an incredibly lucky find.
By now I could see
most of the book
and set about doing a new draft.
The price I was going to have
to pay was becoming obvious.
The story was my discovery
of how my father's fame had
traumatized him, and it had made
a real relationship between us
impossible.
The whole process had
changed the way I saw him,
but also the way I saw myself,
because I now saw how I
had been shaped by his trauma.
And I was going to relive
those feelings nearly every day
as I worked on this book,
because I had to feel them
in order to express them.
The main goal was I wanted
people to read this book
and feel some of what I'd
felt and not be bored by it.
My goal was to create
a graphic novel that
could be very easily read,
that would not be boring,
and would convey emotion.
From this point on, there
were multiple drafts,
and drafts within drafts, as I
tweaked and reworked elements
and removed excess material.
By now I knew this
was not really
a book about old show
business or the war or TV.
This book was about
fathers and sons.
I had my theme.
And the story was
coming into focus.
And everything
extraneous had to go.
The next draft, which is
the one my agent sold,
was different from the
finished book in some ways.
The original art was
much larger-- at least
double page size.
And I was portrayed
realistically.
This was intensely
difficult for me.
I am one of those people
who has a lot of trouble
with their self-image.
I cannot see a photograph of
myself without getting upset
with how ugly I am, how poor
my posture is, how fat I am.
This is an issue I have
struggled with but never
overcome.
I was determined to
try, though, to come up
with a realistic
likeness of myself.
Of course, I could
photograph myself.
But I still had problems with
realizing my physical shape.
So first I drew my
shadow, my shape,
and I started to
work from there.
Ultimately, though,
I decided it would
be best to come up with
a version of myself
that would seem more
universal and the reader
could identify with more easily.
It was a boundary
I struggled with.
And ultimately this book
involves my feelings,
but it's not about me.
It's about him.
That's what I decided.
But there's a later point
in the book's development
where that was underlined
more decisively.
This draft of the book
was delivered to my agent
in July of 2016 and sold by the
end of August to Gallery 13,
a subsidiary of
Simon & Schuster.
I was given an
advance that would
have seemed enormous 10 or
15 years earlier, but not now
with a family and with a
deadline less than a year away.
The task of creating this book
seemed literally impossible.
I had never, ever created a
work of this size or pages
at the rate that
were now required.
I was stricken with terror.
Plus the advance
was not large enough
so I could simply afford
to concentrate on the book.
I would have to do other
work at the same time.
I can still taste the fear.
It all seemed
absolutely impossible.
Adding to the
terror was the fact
that I was determined not to use
the computer so much this time
around.
I wanted to do the art and every
bit of the lettering by hand.
I'd been using a computer font
and other assists for a while.
But I felt they never
looked as good or as real.
I adjusted my attitude and
saw that all of my challenges
were also opportunities.
I wanted the art in this book
to look spontaneous and loose
and feel immediate, not tight
and fussed over and distant.
If I took my original art size
down much closer to print size,
and worked as
quickly as possible,
maybe it would actually
work better for the feeling
I wanted.
It was also an added
incentive to keep
images as simple as possible.
I created model sheets of some
characters and backgrounds
I could use, including my
own homemade zip-a-tone.
I was also doing
weekly comic strips
for two websites,
adultswim.com and "Vice,"
while I created this book.
But that, too, felt
like an opportunity
to keep my hand practiced.
I tried to hypnotize
myself into becoming
a machine of comics creation.
I probably drew close to 300
pages of comics during 2017.
And I lettered them all by hand.
This was an intense challenge
psychically, physically,
and mentally.
And adding to all this
was the psychic trauma
that I was essentially
living in every day.
I had to make the
reader feel the emotions
I felt about my father and the
trauma I now saw I'd inherited.
And that meant I'd have
to live in those emotions.
I'm lucky to have a loyal
and supportive wife.
The book had been due in June.
But that was a soft
deadline, and I actually
delivered the close-to-finished
draft in August.
But there were problems with it.
There literally
wasn't an ending yet.
But also, the final chapter
focused much more on me
and the kind of person my
upbringing had created.
As my editor pointed
out, it had an angry tone
and was at odds with
the rest of the book.
I told him I would fix it.
I took the book back,
thought a lot about it
as quickly as I
could, and then I
completely removed the last
two chapters and reworked them.
I removed most of the
material about myself,
leaving only a few
moments that I felt
summed up our relationship.
I moved our final
painful conversation--
the one where he says nobody
told him he should build
a relationship with me--
from chapter 9 to
chapter 8 and instead,
constructed a more emotional,
elegiac ending that I felt
brought the book full circle.
I submitted this new final
draft in January 2018.
At this point, obviously,
I was well past deadline.
But I had made the original
deadline less relevant
by taking on the responsibility
of doing every piece of it
myself.
After editing, the book was then
copy edited a couple of times,
and nearly all the mistakes
were caught and fixed.
The interior of the
book was completely
finished on February 26.
The cover was finished
at the end of March.
Just as with the insides,
every bit of the cover
was done by my hand,
except the barcode.
I wanted the story to
pull the reader forward,
to feel like an experience.
And I had to leave out
1,000 details and anecdotes
in service of the
narrative flow.
One thing that got left
behind was the idea
that my father came from
the pre-war reality, where
dynamic individuals
dominated the news
and created the inventions
that changed the world,
but then was caught in the
post-war reality, where
committees and organizations
like the men who developed
the atomic bomb became the norm.
Computers took the place of
people in doing calculations.
The first programmable
computer in the United States,
the Mark I, was built by IBM
in a Harvard basement in 1944.
And according to the
press at the time,
it was nicknamed Big Joel.
I'm very proud of the book.
And I think I hit most,
if not all, of my goals.
I think that the story has
an urgency that makes people
want to read it all at once.
I believe I've created
a relatable story
with recognizable emotion.
I'm receiving responses
from people all over,
people I've never met, who
identify with this story.
But there's one way in
which this book has failed.
I really hoped I could build
a connection with my father
before dementia took him.
And I wasn't able to do that.
Maybe I understand him now.
But ultimately, although
there is hope in it,
that's why this is a story of
frustration and loss, which
may be at least partly why
it resonates with others.
We've all felt that
with our families.
Many of us have tried to repair
our families and given up.
It's the human condition.
My son is now nine.
His school sends us emails
complaining about his behavior.
And it's exactly
the same behavior
that was described
in glowing terms
by the reporters who
wrote about my dad.
What was encouraged
is now discouraged.
If my father had
been a child now,
he wouldn't have
been a celebrity.
He would have been drugged, so
he would sit down and shut up.
America tends to extremes.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Hey.
AUDIENCE: Now that you're a
dad, if your son were ever
to write or create
something about you,
what would you hope
that he would say?
MICHAEL KUPPERMAN:
Well, of course,
I'd hope he'd think I
was mostly a good dad,
and had been a good
influence, and tried to not
do what my father did wrong.
AUDIENCE: What does being
a good dad mean to you now?
MICHAEL KUPPERMAN:
Well, I feel for me,
it's about appreciating who
he is and trying to guide him,
so he can be the
person he's supposed
to be and treat other people
nicely at the same time.
He's is a very enabled child,
which can be its own struggle,
because he's very interested.
He's very passionate.
And he can walk all over
other people sometimes.
So I think as a parent,
what I'm trying to do
is guide him to do what
he wants to do but to also
be the best self he could be
and to have manners and body
awareness.
Those are the other main things.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MICHAEL KUPPERMAN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: How do you
feel, as a parent now,
about your father's mother's--
your grandmother's-- choices
raising your father?
MICHAEL KUPPERMAN: I think they
were terrible choices, really
terrible choices.
He should have left the
show after the war ended.
His life would have been
so much better, I think.
The desire to keep him on
TV was just inexplicable.
And it doesn't make
sense from any viewpoint.
Also, she thought he could
have a career in show business.
But she was never canny
enough, for instance,
to negotiate his contract
with "Quiz Kids" again.
So he was making the
same $75 per show
10 years after he
started and was on TV.
It's really hard to think what
she thought the endgame was
or how she thought he
could have been a TV star.
So it's just-- it's
confusing to me,
because it doesn't seem
like good strategy.
And in fact, of course,
it tore the family apart
in a certain way.
So I think it was both bad
parenting, but bad parenting
that's inexplicable in
its kind of pointlessness.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hey, so thanks
for such a wonderful talk.
As someone who read the book,
I found the talk nonetheless
incredibly arresting.
So thank you.
So one of the things that's wild
that comes through in the book
is that your dad was
so insanely famous
and then just wasn't, right?
You didn't even
really know, right?
And I feel like
it's wild that he
went from being so remarkably
well-known in the country
to sort of just forgotten.
And I was wondering if you
could say, what's up with that?
Is that a unique
set of properties
of the difference between
the cataclysm of World War
II and afterwards?
MICHAEL KUPPERMAN:
I think it was.
AUDIENCE: Or is it--
what's up with that?
MICHAEL KUPPERMAN:
No, I think it was.
I think it was a
unique experience.
And the aftermath was unique.
And in some ways,
he was very lucky
as someone who wanted to
escape from it, because--
excuse me-- during
World War II, of course,
people were being told
to recycle all paper.
And there was not much
frivolous merchandise.
So in a way, he was famous
at the best time for it,
if you don't want
to be remembered.
The ability to record video
wasn't invented until '47.
And even then it
was done sparingly.
I think there are three
remaining "Quiz Kids" shows
with him on them.
And radio shows,
there are about 130.
But part of it was that
people weren't that interested
in the past in those days and
in the decades afterwards.
They were excited
about the future.
And nostalgia only
really started
to be a thing, as I remember
it, in the '70s and '80s.
But by then, the people who
really cared about "Quiz Kids"
didn't anymore.
It was a cultural phenomenon.
And his fame was sort of just
a combination of circumstances.
So there was nothing to
bring it back for people
beyond the sentimentality they
individually felt for him.
So he was very
lucky in some ways,
because if he had been
famous now, of course,
he would never have escaped.
The video would be there
forever, the radio.
Everyone would remember him.
And it did take decades.
I was still being
asked by people
if I was related to him until
the late '70s, early '80s.
But then it seemed
to vanish completely.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MICHAEL KUPPERMAN: Sure.
SPEAKER 1: So the
experience seems
to have been a pretty uniformly
terrible one for your father
and to have done tremendous
damage to your family.
Do you think there's any good--
maybe not for you
guys-- but any good
at all that came
out of "Quiz Kids"
and what your
father went through?
MICHAEL KUPPERMAN: Well, I
mean, I'd like to say this book.
I don't know.
It's hard to imagine, since it
was such a profound experience
that really changed
everything in the family,
how things would
have been different.
I suspect my father
would have been
a very different person
had he been allowed
to grow up not on radio and TV.
There were obviously
some good aspects.
The money that he
did make, he used
to buy a house, which was
the house we lived in.
It enabled him to do a few
things he couldn't have
otherwise.
But for the most part, it's hard
to think of other aspects that
were positive.
Certainly for him, it seemed
to be wholly negative, even
the parts that you
might have thought
of as joyous for a child.
He claimed he didn't
enjoy them at all.
So I'd say, apart from the
money, which wasn't much,
and maybe this book, I
can't think of any really.
SPEAKER 1: Sorry.
It's me again.
You mentioned that
some of this seems
to have been intentional
propaganda as part
of the fight against
anti-Semitism
in the United States.
Do you think it had any
effectiveness in that capacity?
Or was it just a good idea--
or maybe not a good idea--
that didn't work out?
MICHAEL KUPPERMAN: Well,
since doing this book,
I've been getting a lot
of responses from people.
And some of them are
actually old enough
to have been around then.
And someone was telling
me just a couple of weeks
ago that it was huge for
his neighborhood in Brooklyn
that there was this
Jewish kid on the radio.
And they were all
very excited about it.
So yeah, maybe it did.
It's possible it did.
You just never know.
I found information about that
side of propaganda very hard
to find.
And in fact, if you look
some places on the internet,
they claim there was no black
propaganda, for instance,
by America during the
war, which is not true.
And I looked and looked for
any kind of a smoking gun
that this was a
deliberately planned thing.
I couldn't find one, of course,
not that I thought I would.
But I had to look.
But I think it was
a deliberate choice
to put him on radio
as a Jewish child
and to build up his image.
But even if he wasn't,
that was still the effect.
So it was either accidental, or
intentional, or part of each.
But I have found citations
that Lewis G Cowan
inserted propagandistic
messages in American radio
shows to improve the image
of minorities and servicemen
and so on, and also was doing
radio propaganda for overseas,
and was involved in the creation
of the Armed Forces Radio,
and would insert
messages meant to be
heard by the opposite side
in some radio shows too.
During-- when I was
looking at his papers
at Columbia University,
I found a mention
that when he put a
message in a radio show
and he wanted it
heard by the enemy,
they made sure that
the announcer read it
at quote unquote
"dictation speed," which
was very interesting.
So it's something I strongly
suspect and feel to be true.
But I have no solid proof of it.
But I think there was a
positive effect, possibly,
by all these Jewish
kids being featured.
I don't know for sure though.
Anyone else?
SPEAKER 1: Well, Mr. Kupperman,
thank you so much for coming.
This was an absolutely
fantastic and moving talk.
Some of it was
honestly a little hard
to watch-- that clip of
your father on television.
And as moving as
your book is, it
was an entirely different
experience hearing
you talk about this live.
So thank you so much for coming.
MICHAEL KUPPERMAN: Thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]